j'ai le sentiment que les dettes les
crédits tout ça ça vous est familier la
situation n'est pas très brillante ici
ça peut vous rassurer on n'est pas
vraiment encore au fond on n'est pas
loin mais on y est pas encore
franchement ça me rassure énormément
si vous voulez boire des coups et parler
justice sociale on est à la ruche
je t'invite puis la rue c'est très sympa
c'est gratuit en plus donc toi tu
m'invites mais c'est gratuit c'est
exactement ça certains prévois 45 degrés
en 2050 je suis désolé en
ceinte exactement
[Musique]
s'il te plaît j'ai pris libre tu choisis
entre 0 et 5 € et je vais je vais te
donner zéro
beaucoup plus musc
[Musique]
lée
c'est bon monsieur allez on y va
et là on fait une sensibilisation sur la
climatique est-ce que tu as un ballon
[Musique]
on est en train de fabriquer des
générations sur consommateurs qu'on
puisse
un cri d'alarme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ce que je leur ai offert à mes
neveux
cette année je vous offre toute mon
estime et tous mes encouragements
[Musique]
de passer un Noël avec toi et c'est pas
cher et c'est pas cher
[Musique]